disney is almost always family friendly
almost which classic disney film
secretly included a topless photo of a
woman keep watching to find out
fans love to try and spot hidden
messages in disney films usually these
are a little more than urban legends but
once in a while there's actually
something there like the photo of a
topless woman that was inserted into the
rescuers the two frames in question
can't be spotted at normal speed and
thus wasn't noticeable in the film's
1977 theatrical release when it came to
a 1999 home video release however
viewers were able to slow it down and
catch the image during the scene in
which miss bianca and bernard are taking
flight about to embark on their
adventure this led to disney requesting
a recall of over 3.4 million copies of
the offending tapes previous accusations
of adult content in disney films has
been shrugged off by the company but the
fact that disney recalled the rescuers
proved that this one was very much real
when you think of the 1955 disney
classic lady and the [ __ ] the first
image that would usually spring to mind
would be the iconic scene of the two
love struck dogs sharing a romantic bowl
of spaghetti together the memorable
moment is frequently cited as one of the
most romantic scenes in cinema however
this scene almost didn't make the cut
and it was walt disney himself that was
skeptical about it while keen for the
animals to display human emotions he did
wonder whether showing them enjoying a
meal together was a step too far in real
life two dogs sharing a plate of food
would probably be a bit of a messy
experience and the concern was that this
scene would lack the finesse and grace
to give it that romantic feel directing
animator frank thomas was able to save
the day however working on a rough
version of the scene to convince walt
that it could be included in the film
with just a sprinkle of disney magic
fortunately walt was convinced and the
scene made it into the film and was of
course recreated once again in the 2019
live action version of the film
in a film that features talking animals
and song and dance numbers the
suspension of disbelief is essential
when it came to the lion king however it
was the portrayal of the villainous
sidekicks that landed disney in some
trouble with a hyena expert the hyenas
and the lion king are the loyal henchmen
of the villainous scar known for their
haunting cackle general ineptitude and
being very much at the bottom of the
pecking order when it comes to hunting
some biologists were so incensed by the
way the hyenas were portrayed as
villains that they published articles
seeking to clear the good name of hyenas
everywhere a piece by lawrence frank of
the university of california berkeley
even went as far as calling for a
boycott of the lion king while a boycott
might seem quite extreme the experts may
well have been onto something as
subsequent research has debunked many of
the myths about these
creatures while she may seem like she
was born to play the part of belle emma
watson's disney journey almost ended
very differently when she was offered
and turned down the role of cinderella
in recent years the former harry potter
star has become as well known for her
advocacy work as un ambassador for women
the depiction of the characters she's
playing on screen is something that she
considers before accepting a role
concerned that cinderella wouldn't
provide a strong enough feminist role
model for young girls watson rejected
the part which subsequently went to lily
james the role of belle piqued her
interest however as it felt much more
closely aligned to her feminist ideals
she even had influence over the writing
of the character in the 2017 live-action
version of beauty and the beast
requesting more of a backstory that
added further depth to the character it
was perhaps a smart decision on the part
of watson as disney's 2015 live-action
retelling of cinderella garnered some
controversy particularly regarding the
strict diet that was required of lily
james in order to fit into the costumes
the corset pulls it in and then the
skirt makes it bigger so i think the
perspective makes it look
look even smaller
in the golden age of disney walt had
complete power and influence over the
creative output of his studio and with
bambi in particular he was adamant that
every aspect of this film would be
perfect he went to extraordinary lengths
to ensure accuracy when making the film
including shipping real dear to the
burbank studio and hiring an animal
anatomist to ensure his artist's
drawings were as close to the real thing
as possible while these painstaking
lengths paid off in the end it
undoubtedly created quite a stressful
environment for the animators and staff
working on the film as they worked
preparing for the nitpicking that would
come with walt's daily visits to the
studio they adopted a phrase among
themselves to signal his arrival to each
other one of the most iconic lines in
bambi takes place after humans show up
in the film for the first time and all
the deer have to run and hide why did we
all run
man
was in the forest
well according to a profile from the new
england historical society when walt was
spotted coming down the corridor the
artists would say man is in the forest
to warn their peers that the boss was on
his way
over the decades disney has dealt with
some pretty tumultuous events and box
office flops and somehow continued to
thrive notable examples include world
war ii when the studio lost much of its
workforce and its revenue to the war
effort and had to make cobbled together
anthologies like melody time instead of
feature films similarly in the era
following walt's death in 1966 the
studio was left without clear direction
and purpose and with small budgets had
to work a lot harder in order to keep
producing films animation in particular
is costly in both money and time so
occasionally some cost cutting methods
were used to keep things going one of
the methods employed was the use of
rotoscoping an animation technique that
animators used to trace over existing
footage rotoscoping was particularly
evident in 1973's robin hood this
animated tale of the legendary outlaw
reused animation from the disney
archives including scenes from snow
white the aristocats and the jungle book
the disney artists have never denied
using this technique and while it's
especially apparent in robin hood they
also later used it in beauty and the
beast which borrows some of its ballroom
dancing animation from sleeping beauty
the cost cutting paid off and ensured
that robin hood could be made for around
5 million
far less than what some later films
would cost
as the scale and scope of their films
have grown over the years disney's
movies have also seen a huge increase in
budget their first animated film snow
white had a budget of around 1.49
million dollars which equates to around
28.3 million dollars when adjusted for
inflation 2019's frozen two meanwhile
cost around 150 million dollars to make
however there's one film which stands
above them all in terms of cost not just
in the realm of disney's own history but
holding firm as the most expensive
animated film ever made the film in
question is 2010s tangled which cost an
astronomical 260 million dollars it's
not hard to see where the budget went on
this film with the animation being among
the most striking disney has ever
produced and as you can imagine
animating over 140 000 individual
strands of hair is a costly process
additionally the project went through a
slightly troubled production with plenty
of rewrites and a complete change of
focus before it became the film it is
today initially intended as a more
sarcastic reimagining of the fairy tale
think shrek supervising animator glenn
keane reworked the story to make it much
more sincere the film represented a huge
breakthrough for the disney of the 21st
century ushering in a new era for
disney's princess movies and paving the
way for films like frozen and raya and
the last dragon
long before he brought his unique
visionary style to the reimagining of
alice in wonderland in 2010 tim burton
had a connection with disney that went
as far back as 1980 when he was offered
an apprentice position at the studio
after graduating from the california
institute of arts burton joined disney
and worked as an apprentice animator on
the fox and the hound under the watchful
eye of veteran animators in addition to
this burden has uncredited rules working
on tron and the black cauldron despite
the studio giving him his big break he
felt it was stunting him creatively so
after only a year he parted ways in
order to explore more of his own unique
style and vision the split was clearly
amicable however as burton went on to be
involved with many other disney projects
including the nightmare before christmas
alice in wonderland and the live-action
version of dumbo
ursula the sea witch from the little
mermaid is arguably one of the most
memorable disney villains of them all
but the real life inspiration for her
design came from the unlikeliest of
places the drag queen known as divine
divine was the muse of director john
waters starring in a number of his films
including pink flamingos if you're not
familiar with water's work his films are
about as far away from disney as you can
get could you give us some of your
political beliefs kill everyone now
condone first degree murder advocate
cannibalism
animator rob minkoff toyed with many
ideas for the design of ursula starting
off with a very thin almost as he put it
joan collins-esque character ursula
eventually evolved into the buxom
sorceress we know and loved today after
songwriter howard ashman spotted a
sketch that bore a close resemblance to
divine and decided this would be the
perfect look for the character sadly
devine never got to see the completed
film dying shortly before the little
mermaid was released in 1988 but
documentarian jeffrey schwartz director
of the 2013 film i am divine feels that
the icon would have not only loved the
character but would have wanted to play
the role if given the chance
disney certainly isn't afraid of going
there when it comes to distressing dark
or downright disturbing content however
way back in 1937 audiences perhaps
weren't prepared for how frightening
their first feature length offering
would be according to brad bird director
of pixar classics ratatouille and the
incredibles disney has never been afraid
to scare children he claims that a month
after the film's initial theatrical
release upholstered theater seats
reportedly had to be replaced because
children would frequently wet themselves
in fright when the witch came on
we've all been there that heart and
mouth moment where you think you might
have closed down a document without
saving it or think you've lost something
valuable to you for one
over-enthusiastic member of staff at
pixar their momentary lapse in judgement
almost erased an entire film yes while
pixar was working on the much
anticipated toy story 2 someone
accidentally ran a command on their
computer system that erased almost all
the work they had done on the movie one
might reasonably have questions about
why such a button would even exist
it was then discovered that the
automatic backup system hadn't been
working so there was no backup for the
movie toy story 2 was just gone
fortunately supervising technical
director galen sussman had been working
on the film from home on maternity leave
and suggested that film could be
restored from her personal computer
against all odds the team managed to
piece the film back together using the
files on her computer and save the day
in perhaps a rather cruel twist of fate
much of the restored work ended up being
scrapped anyway as the film went through
a pretty extensive series of rewrites
that saw much of what had been animated
getting altered in some way check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite disney films are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you